hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in
nico mccain ethics book five
aristotle discusses three sorts of what
he calls
particular justice so this is different
from
justice as complete virtue or justice as
legality or law-abidingness and
how do we understand justice as
particular
well he he says that justice
embodies a certain kind of fairness or a
certain kind of
equality and the greek word is isotex
means the equal and it can mean equal in
the very strict sense of
five is equal to two plus three you know
total equality
but it also has a broader sense in which
it means uh
something like that which is actually
appropriate that which is deserved
that which is proportionate as aristotle
is going to
talk about it now that's a use that that
aristotle himself
is emphasizing more strongly i think
than
other people before him one of the very
important ways
in which we can talk about things being
fair or being equal or being appropriate
is in terms of what we would call
distribution
or allotment or assignment
and if we're talking about justice in
these these sorts of things what are we
what do we have in mind we have in mind
certain
good things and certain bad things
this can be as simple as ladling out the
food at the table or dividing up a candy
bar among several
children it can be about
people getting to take their turn on the
playground
having a similar amount of time
given to them for tutoring
it could be about a lot of things for
students it might be about grades are
grades distributed in a fair way or are
they distributed
in an unequal and unfair a arbitrary
manner
these are questions that that we can ask
when it comes to
these sorts of goods and what are other
good or bad things that we can
distribute aristotle
who's much more focused on the adult
world and the adult world of the greeks
talks for example about distributing
honors
and honors are where we are saying
somebody is
above other people they they excel in a
certain way
where we accord them a certain kind of
prestige or a certain celebrity
in in contemporary terms where we give
them
a trophy a metal a gold star and it
could be that there are cases where
it's appropriate that everybody gets a
gold star for showing up
the olympics for example is not one of
those you know
with the olympics you have
first place gets the gold medal and
second place gets a silver medal
and third place gets the bronze medal
and what does fourth place get
nothing what does fifth place get the
same nothing what does last place get
the same nothing
and so you know not everybody gets
something based on showing up
on participating maybe they're all you
know
given room and board the same that's
equal
but they're not um given the same honors
as
as everybody else is what else wealth
wealth is is a big one this can
encompass income this can encompass
property this can encompass
basic things like food at the table
the kind of property the kind of housing
that one has
chalkboards could be a type of wealth
cameras could be a type of wealth we
could
you know clothing we can think in all
these sorts of terms
um position this is one that aristotle
doesn't talk about
per se here but he does talk about quite
a bit in the politics
how do we assign offices how do we you
know
decide who's going to qualify for civil
service
who is going to be given positions of
authority
who's going to be demoted who's going to
be promoted who gets you know
the chance to distribute the office
supplies you know
whether one gets to distribute things
might be itself an
office that is part of a distribution
so these are all important things and
then we can think about
aristotle doesn't talk about this but
this is a very modern
obsession opportunity is everybody being
given fair opportunities to say get a
job
to go to college
um find somebody who they they can fall
in love with
or are they being deprived of
opportunities are there opportunities
being lessened
do we need to to readjust who has
opportunities and who doesn't have
opportunities
again you know there could be a lot of
cases where we say well it should be
totally equal across the board and there
may be some cases where we say no some
people merit something more and some
people merit something less
so we have a lot of different goods that
we can think of
we can also think of a lot of different
bad things as well
what would be examples of bad things
that we might have to think about in
terms of distribution
um we could think for example about
taxes
taxes are when you take away wealth
generally telling people you have to
give something of this and
are taxes distributed equally
are they distributed fairly these are
these are the sorts of questions that we
want to ask when we're thinking about
justice as sort of a structure
what about exposure to pollution
exposure to
infectious diseases access to
health care all of these sorts of things
could fit into what aristotle is calling
distributive justice
any one of them can be the object of it
so when we think of equality aristotle
wants to stress to us that
we should think of equality as a kind of
middle position
not too much not too little just as with
any of the
the virtues that he's been talking about
so
if for example the right amount of
money for me as a
professor of philosophy which you know
this is very hard to figure out let's
say the right amount is fifty thousand
dollars a year or a hundred thousand
dollars a year
um if that's the case for me then for
somebody else who has the same
relevant qualifications and training
they should get the same amount
or perhaps we make it very on you know
time and service the longer that you're
in you get you get raises
or perhaps we make it depend on what
sort of
you know additional work you've done
what service work what sort of
uh publishing and maybe even you know
what video courses you've put together
there's a lot of different ways in which
we can think about this but one way that
we think about it
is that look there's a middle position
and if if there's too much
then that's unjust or if there's too
little then that's unjust
and the basic assumption governing
all of this is that we're talking about
goods
that can be shared can be transferred
can be
you know pushed from one person to
another
or one area to another
but they're finite they're limited
because otherwise we could just give
everybody totally
everything as far as wealth well no
wealth is
something that it's vast but it is
limited and if i have
your income not just an income like
yours but your income that means you
don't have it
so these are very important things to
keep in mind
aristotle says that
people often go wrong by thinking that
justice is simply
strict equality equality
is appropriate in some circumstances
like i said
there may be some classroom exercises
where everybody
should get a gold star for handing it in
but there there are other criteria
other than just showing up or
participation
or willingness and we use those to
determine
how we ought to distribute these goods
in these bands
so the big question we always have to
ask is what is the criteria
aristotle tends to think that most
people
not only air by you know do doing too
much
too little not appropriating things not
not
distributing them entirely the way they
ought to
but also in picking the wrong criteria
or in focusing on the wrong criteria or
giving the wrong criteria too much
weight
so for example let's take a classic
example that we use in moral theory
should the doctor in a doctor's office
be paid
exactly the same amount as the nurse
who puts in just as many hours as the
doctor
and should both of them be paid the same
amount as the secretary who handles
bookings and calls
and the custodial staff who comes in at
night and cleans the place up
now you could say well the doctor makes
you know
way too much in comparison to these
people but we're not asking about
whether
i'm not asking about the exact
proportion at this point we're just
asking the basic question
should it be totally equal across the
board
and most of us would be willing to say
so would aristotle
no in fact the doctor should get more
income
perhaps not as you know some
astronomical sum
uh the way that it sometimes works out
but should get more income
than the other people and a nurse who
has
you know some training and does fulfill
a vital
role should get more than the secretary
who does also perform a vital role but
it doesn't require as much training to
be a secretary
there's a certain proportion between
them and figuring out exactly what that
proportion is
that's where we have to get into to you
know more uh concrete
determinations and so we're not going to
try to do that here we're not going to
say
well doctors should earn precisely four
times as much as nurses
but there is some recognition there
that some people should get more and
other people should get
get less we could think about the same
thing with ceo pay
it's very clear that ceos uh
are paid astronomical sums when we start
counting in benefits and
and not only in terms of you know mere
wealth but also the opportunities that
they're given
the amount of power that they're given
the amount of prestige that they're
given
and their lack of exposure to
ironically because they're supposed to
be the great entrepreneurs their lack of
exposure
to um to harm
in comparison to to many of the
employees and
aristotle would probably look at our ceo
pay here in america
and say they're earning way too much
they should be earning
more quite a bit more than the average
worker
but probably not you know 300 400 500
times
as much so it's important to know
what is the criteria by which we are
apportioning good or bad things
if we pick the wrong criteria and what
is our temptation our temptation is to
pick the criteria
that we feel is the best oftentimes in a
self-serving way so
aristotle says people in a democracy
those who are for the democracy often
want to say well we should all get an
equal share
um and those who see some sort of
you know merit-based thing whether it's
a sort of
let's call it a silly merit-based thing
based on wealth
or good birth and oligarchy or a very
you know commonsensical merit-based
thing like
error like merit in an aristocracy a
real aristocracy
means the people who who are the best
actually
have virtues they have excellences
beyond those of other people maybe they
should get
um something else and aristotle says all
three of them tend to go wrong the
democrats tend to think well you know
being free birth or equality or being a
citizen means we all get the same thing
the rich of course think well because
i'm rich i'm entitled to more
uh and and even the virtuous he says can
go too
far in asserting the claims of virtue
although they're much less likely to do
so
in part because they are virtuous
one great example of this where
aristotle would say
both sides are kind of getting it right
and both sides are kind of getting it
wrong would be voter id laws
if you think about you know what is a
voter id law about it's really about
an opportunity the opportunity to
perform a very very tiny tiny role
within the functioning of a nation-state
democracy
at a local level of course your vote has
has you know more weight
than in a national election
now requiring of people that they
actually be able to show a photo id
in in a you know in in states where
most people have driver's licenses and
if you want to get a photo id
it's pretty pretty easy to do so
does not seem like a particularly
onerous
thing to demand of people but it is a
criteria
it's it's a criterion for who gets to
vote
you're distributing the right to vote in
a certain sense based on whether you
satisfy certain criteria there's other
criteria as well you actually have to be
alive sometimes
dead people vote you actually have to
live in that area where you're voting
but but you know let's say all those
other things are satisfied
um very clearly
you know the legislation that gets
proposed about voter id laws
has multiple reasons behind it one of
the reasons is to cut down on fraud
one of the reasons is also to stick it
to uh
you know some some other uh part of the
the uh constituency and i would say that
holds for both
both sides both the republicans and the
democrats
are essentially trying to further their
own interest and consolidate their own
their own power by engaging in these
laws
by you know either for or against
aristotle would you know probably take a
look at this and he would probably come
down
on the side of the yeah it makes good
sense to say
if you can't do the work to get yourself
an id you probably shouldn't be voting
anyway but that's aristotle
but it's a good example of this sort of
thing we could also look at the
distribution
of welfare benefits in a state we could
look at the distribution
of food networks we could look at how it
works
with education all of those can be a
matter of distributive justice for
aristotle